I saw the lady who reads peace
to be sure and
thank God Oh
jeez
like mr. Lima Dental of our we're gonna
is going to make for a very interesting
discussion because
oh very
never
so she especially
[Applause]
sure from
that could not be respectful
is to be believable
yes sure
so this is was recently posted by James
Whalen as everyone knows he's one of the
most prominent Christian scholars and
this is what he said he said just a just
a note on Christmas and I had a
wonderful day of celebration I cannot
see how reflective a Muslim could say
Merry Christmas to a Christian not that
week we should not be kind and friendly
to each other and friend one another and
he and he continued to say but let me
honest let me be honest if you shine is
true Islam is not and vice-versa
Christmas involved not only incarnation
have Aries the very son of God the
central Christian doctrine deemed nearly
impossible in the Islamic theology and
at the ended of the post this is what he
said it makes no sense to me to expect a
Muslim to compromise their faith to wish
me a Merry Christmas nor I would funded
a bit at least bit offensive but what I
what I don't know you know when it comes
to interfaith dialogue and debates and
discussion here Muslims so I belief is
quite honest when he's saying this
compared to some other scholars who kind
of compromise our beliefs or their
beliefs he's standing for his position
and he's respecting our position and
he's respecting us that we don't greet
with Merry Christmas but we still
respect what they believe so it's
important that he's taking that position
that find his ok Muslims don't greet the
Christian friends with Merry Christmas
is fine with it we understand
he acknowledges that and that's
important so how do you feel now because
you have some people who have heard some
people knowledge
some Islamic universities wouldn't say
that such conventions mean they'll say
when asked is it okay to say Merry
Christmas and then they'll say that as
long as it's in your heart you don't
believe it to be true what
what does actually signifies then it's
okay well I think I mean the issue here
is the following is no one denies the
fact that we should be good we should be
decent we should be treating up Muslim
friends with the with the best of
manners no one would deny that and ask
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala said in the
Quran layin how come Allah and in latina
let me go party lucuma Dini OLM lucre do
come in the Erika and Tom what really
Palace heart Allah does not forbid you
for those who did not fight with you and
or kicked you out of your houses for you
to be gentle and nice with them yes we
indeed always want to be nice and we
want to be gentle and we want to treat
our neighbors with the midst of way but
in the same token when it comes to
religious matters and without but here
ideologies and wished it it absolutely
convicts the essence of list what Islam
is what is them is they believe in and
not only that even even with him and as
we said in the past you know even if it
convicts other Christian denominations
to because you know there is there is no
consensus the fact that you know
Christmas in the 25th of December among
all the Christian denominations so with
that being said it's it's a weave we
find it that you know it's kind of
colored because if you asked any Muslim
you know what what do we believe if
Jesus we say that we believe in him as a
prophet of God
but in the same token what what did you
Christians believe of Jesus and why they
celebrate Christmas because they believe
he was the son of God and so there is
two difference there is a continuity
condition that exists here between our
ideology and theirs and we don't we'll
have to add you know compromise our
faith by congratulating them but we
still could be nice and gentle with them
and and adding in any occasions all
throughout the year
some would say that long as you don't
believe what you say you say Merry
Christmas not a problem
sure sure you know the word Merry
Christmas these are not just two simple
English words that you're happy that
Jesus was born he's be upon him many
Merry Christmas they have connotations
for our faith and their faith so when we
look from the Christian point of view
Christ was God son of God he was divine
give us his part of the Trinity he is
fully God fully human came down died for
our sins and salvation is believing in
that that's how they go to paradise so
so Christ and Christmas and Merry
Christmas they come with all of this
baggage all of this connotation there's
not just simple happy birth of Christ
all of this we are acknowledging we are
authenticating and we are saying that
you know fine we're happy that you're
believe in all of this we respect it but
we don't ignore it's really simple every
faith has their bottoms our border is
there there is only one God and was
and that he appointed messengers and
prophets for the love of humanity and
one of those mighty messengers was none
other than Jesus Christ peace be upon
him fully human you know he was a blood
he was bones he was human later but a
mighty prophet so he received the
message of allah subhanaw taala
to invite humanity to the worship of one
God so it's important for us respecting
them but you know what she said is
important we have to be nice gentle
compassionate helping with every person
regardless of their belief truth that's
what the Prophet taught us but brother
Eddie if I love my neighbor who's a
Christian my best hope that I can give
that person it's not just giving a gift
or greeting with happy holidays are
helping pray you know clean the snow on
the sidewalk if I love my neighbor I
want to help my neighbor by telling him
or her the truth just like we want to go
to Jannah paradise if I love my neighbor
I want him to also go to paradise so the
best help we can give is not Merry
Christmas
maybe Happy Holidays but telling them
the truth the reality who is honest
along was and who he was not so what do
we get out of the
dr. James white who if you paraphrase
what he's saying are we understanding
that he's saying that I don't expect
Muslims to because
because by saying he's saying that
you're actually compromising your faith
is that what he's saying I mean when you
have a Christian prominent Christian
scholars who do group makes the clear
connection between what is male
Christmas is and their ideology and they
send there's a direct connections
between what is Mayor Christmas is the
what the Christian believers and but by
us congratulating them we are kind of
acknowledging the fact that you know you
know that Jesus is the Son of God
he is the incarnation of God he is part
of the Trinity so he it's a clear clear
contradictions and we don't as Muslims
you know you know we don't have to
compromise our faith by by admitting or
by congratulating you know our you know
Christian burdens in humanity the fact
that you know there you know if mayor
Christmas or etc I really found it you
know kind of a paradox if he asked me in
fact that you know we believe that one
of the most greatest sins in Islam is
associating anyone with God and and no
no Muslim would deny that in the same
token how could we congratulate or marry
other person of when they didn't do it
when they're doing less of a sense like
for instance you're not gonna see me
approaching mother I do congratulation
and commit you committing that sin or
you coming to me congratulate me in
committing that sin or acknowledging
that no but in the same token you know
we're not gonna we're not going we're
not going to compromise you know the one
of the most important aspect of our
religion which is monotheism worshiping
one God not associating anyone with
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala and saying
that and i you know that you know merry
christmas on that day because this is a
religious matter yes we agree respect
them we we should be you know a promise
or a lot i said i'm have have asked us
to to to be to be nice to our neighbors
to smell their faces to take care of
them to to visit their sick but i same
token when it comes to the concept of
faith i think we have this is a red line
that we can across our fortunately
you know something about inferiority
complex so what I meant is that we have
to be confident in our belief that we
are on the right path the path of
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him and
all the prophets of Allah votes main
message was to submit Allah subhanAllah
not to any human in worship or creation
animals idols so it's important we have
to be proud that Allah has blessed us so
just to make other people happy about
their faith if I feel that one of our
scholars whenever Muslims when they
greet other people with Merry Christmas
sometimes we have want to please them so
much that it appears as if you are
diluting our faith it appears as if now
we don't have any boundaries that they
are ok and we are ok and that is
dangerous yes as you mentioned 100
percent correctly Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu less Allah even with the
idol worshippers and of the mushrikeen
and the Christians and the Jews he used
to work with them you know that that
charter of all different foods already
so in that way he was working with all
of them for the betterment of society
regardless of creed nationality and
culture and race so yes as humans we can
and we should is example coming from the
Sunnah and from the Quran obviously but
by greeting with Merry Christmas
you are getting all the baggage and
saying what you're doing is right so we
should be proud of our faith we are
followers of Prophet Jesus peace be upon
the true followers me epistle assalam
and when we are diluting our faith by
saying Merry Christmas
it appears as if we are having that
inferiority complex we should be
confident we should teach our children
that yes we have the best faith and that
should motivate us for the love of
humanity to share that faith with you
of course yeah so the thing is I mean
just as dr. Simeon has mentioned we
don't we're not obligated to do anything
because thing is we take the Muslims out
of the picture even among the Christian
denomination themselves is that is
Christmas in Animus Lee on the 25th of
December no it's not you know it differs
when it comes to the Coptics if Egypt
when it comes to the Orthodox to the CAF
the Catholic and present day and even a
few billions Christians all of them
salable celebrated in different times of
the year you know and as we Muslims you
know we believe the fact that prophet
Jesus taught was Stella was not even
born in the winter you know we believe
that it was born in the sinasohn a
summer according to the to the to the
third floor at maryam and even when it
comes to the even the christians i mean
even even actually the Pope admits in a
to a recent article that was released
that you know Jesus was not born in the
winter times this is a fact you know
when you look at the book according to
the Book of Luke when they says that
Jesus was born when the Shepherd's was
out in the field you know what sure is
that you know he was not really
it's I mean it was mainly an official
Christian Brethren's admit this they
said that fat where this was adopted
from the pagan beliefs in which disease
so there have been many so-called you
know God's sense of God mediators that
they were born from the 24-ton code born
and the 25th of December making that and
one of the example is Mitra
Mithra is a person Portia born
apparently on the 25th he is called the
son of God born to a virgin had 12
disciples died for the sins of humanity
and resurrected so obvious what we what
we see that Christians say about prophet
Jesus peace be upon him
it is almost hundred percent borrowed
from the pagan idealistic faiths of the
past so it's important for us not to
fall into that trap and acknowledging
what the Christian scholars acknowledge
that these things are borrowed Jesus was
not born on the 25th of December peace
be upon him and even the Bible says
whether October 1 is here that the main
message of Jesus peace be upon him is
none of the things that what
Christians believe his main message was
the message of the absolute oneness of
God worshiping the creator and not the
creation mark chapter 12 verse number 28
and 29 so a person came to Jesus peace
be upon him so this is in the Bible a
Jewish person and asked him a
million-dollar question of all the
commandments which one is the first the
greatest of all of them and Jesus peace
be upon him as a Messenger of God he
mentioned in mark chapter chapter 12
verse 29 here o Israel the Lord our God
is only one worship him not me not
somebody else worship Him with all your
heart mind soul and strength and that is
the first commandment
so using this occasion of the 25th of
December and the holiday season and
there are celebrations this should give
us an opportunity to break the ice with
our colleagues and neighbors and friends
and strangers about who Jesus is the
reality so for that reason I'm not sure
dr. Marvin in Chicago we have a
billboard yeah we have a billboard by
game piece and the main message of the
billboard is I'm not sure if you have
seen the billboard find Jesus in the
Quran o Muhammad peace be upon him in
the Bible just to inside there make them
curious and interested that look at the
side of what Muslims believe
the right site and the site about
monotheism which was the main message of
Jesus peaceful Allah do you see that
because it seems like as years go on
that we start hearing many opinions a
more stranger and stranger at one point
I was pretty shocked because thing is in
and I could say this with full
confidence when you got when you go into
the the old Islamic literature you're
not gonna find this even a dispute among
the Muslim scholars whether to
congratulate Muslims non-muslims in
their religious the religious holidays
or not and even if the Korean male is
hardly visible they may have an
extensive research about this is most at
this time where people were celebrating
this and doing this and he said that it
he did not find any difference in
opinions in the plane they saying this
he did not find any difference in
opinions when it comes to congratulating
non non Muslims and their you know
religious religious holidays so but now
unfortunately you know you know the fact
that you know people feel feel like you
know we have to kind of change our
religion we have to kind of turn it down
a little bit we have to you know make be
everybody happy you know people start
changing things and I think this is kind
of you know some time put the Muslims in
a this not not so much a good situation
marwan said we here tone it down a bit
one of the ramifications doing some of
these things save some of these things
is just being like it's not a big deal
you know this is a slippery slope we all
know it this is just in a common sense
you know no-brainer it's a slippery
slope
maybe the scholar or the some you know a
few Muslim scholars if they are saying
it's okay to say Merry Christmas maybe
they have a different intention maybe
they have a different meaning but the
crowd their follower specially over you
when they hear that you know this Muslim
scholar says it's okay to say Merry
Christmas now this young person who may
not have full understanding of our
theology and the theology of the
Christians they may start to acknowledge
it may be appreciated and who knows we
are going down the slippery slope so
it's important that intention may be
right but intention is not the only
thing in Islam the process also has to
be connected through so the best example
for us is prophet muhammad's and
analysis they were mushrikeen with their
own holidays they were Jews and
Christians with their own holidays the
Prophet never imitated never greeted
them but at the end of the day he worked
with all of them true form of just
society and that is the example we need
to fall now both of you are
both board-certified medical doctor yeah
you know specialist in your field you
also dedicate your life to outreach the
sharing the message of purpose in life
of this Dean's way of life so you have a
lot of interactions with that not yet
Muslims and they come not yet whistles
everyone has in them to give birth to
Authority inside to cite to the creator
of inside her
just like Jesus Moses Abraham class mr.
Dayal tobias1 God do you find people
because you interact with a lot of
people people respect you a lot of times
people feel have more respect for me
more more respect for me when they know
what I'm coming from and why and that's
oh because thing is look nothing that
offended because as dr. Simeon have said
this is open an opportunity for us to
explain how our faith like versus how
come here and say Merry Christmas then
is gonna be a golden opportunity that
was given to me in a golden plate for me
to talk about my faith you know so and I
think is to be honest like you know the
you know like I said me there is other
ways for us to be nice and junk food is
I mean we could say thank you you know
what I don't have to reply Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas thank you
we wish you a very good we wish you a
good day etc so what I mean like I said
there's other ways that we could avoid
this and end this conversation in the
best of ways without compromising our
faith no no making the other people feel
you know there are no imposition for
them to to marry it may make merry
Christmas to me but again this is you
know at the end of the day when people
know our positions when people will see
you know the fact that why we're not
saying Merry Christmas
it's an opportunity for them to know
more about Islam
99 of the 99% of the time awesome
experience
yes yes you know there's always one
question of the people if you don't
reply to them the way that they expect
us to reply you can keep on saying Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas they want that
response you know yeah merry Christmas
to you too but we can say as you
mentioned in happy holidays holiday I
celebrate holidays right my kids are
officers yeah so it's important people
like it if we are holding to our
principles the simple example I'm part
of this group all the Toastmasters the
very first day I mentioned to the whole
group so this is a this is a group that
teaches people how to be better
communicators I am the only Muslim there
when I went there I found out that it is
a tradition for people that as they come
to speak in front of everyone they shake
hands male/female No Boundaries they
shake hands when I saw it the very first
time I mentioned to the president of the
group saying that out of respect to you
and for the sake of modesty in my
religion I don't shake hands with the
people of opposite gender and I cannot
touch and she really appreciated that
she went in the front of the whole group
and she said you know we have to respect
Sabir and his faith so when I approached
to speak for my practice they go like
this and I go like that so that spurred
them to ask me questions about Muslim so
look at it if we hold true to our
principles with confidence Allah opens
more doors on that we helpers to educate
them about the true teachings of Islam
you go
telling people of course not I mean like
I said I'm not gonna impose something on
people that I would die yeah
so I'm not gonna enforce something on an
individual that they have known they
know nothing about my faith no one
expected nor the other way around that's
the issue once we open this door is not
gonna close
there is a beautiful hadith and I like
to I want my our Muslim brothers and
sisters understand how deep this is the
authentic hadith in which prophet
muhammad salla allah said I said that
Allah Allah Tala is most patient on all
of us in which son of Adam human ate him
every day while he still makes provision
for them how the son of Adam humiliating
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala by claiming that
he has a son
so the question so this is again a clear
contradictions you know you know you
know and I lost my dad I said an
identified problem on our victim che and
in them you know and they say that we
have God have a son
indeed he have come up with something
big so so here again we're not trying to
offend anyone or but this is our belief
we believe that God you know Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala nothing is like him
you know God cannot beget a son he
because he is unique he's the one he's
the only one and to be honest I mean
let's be frank
the huge believe the same thing the Jews
don't you know this is a reality the
Jews believe in the only one God he does
that you know with all of these nasty
things God again
don't is it is it it's the direction but
they actually yeah they don't breathe
and I am talking the anthology he's
conducted enough art according to the
talmud and other books they have wrong
things nasty things not only about Jesus
peace be upon by his mother - what about
his mother all the nasty things so I
think there's also one of the topics we
can quickly enlighten our viewers so
sometimes what I do with our fellow
brothers and sisters of humanity the
Christians is that this gives us an
opportunity I will quiz them especially
in the in the in this season do you know
there is a book in which Mary's
mentioned mother Mary peace be upon her
she is mentioned 32 times with respect
and honor as being as the best of all
the ladies ever do you know who she used
or who do you think that what do you
think that book is because it may spark
them the curiosity and that I mentioned
in them here she's mentioned 32 times
but only 18 times in the New Testament
then I smile at them and say you know we
respect her model so again these
opportunities can be used to spark
conversation and to enlighten them bring
them close to the Quran and to the
Prophet and his large
supporting amazing so again we have
you're all brothers and sisters in
humanity we have the same trial to Adam
and now if you choose to go
and worship the creation Jesus smoked
whoever the National belief
at the end of the day we try to call
people away for that because that's what
Moses Abraham and all these messengers
tried to do at the end of the day that
Almighty is the ultimate judge he's
telling us how we need to live according
to it and this is like the message for
all people but at the end of the day we
are here on earth we need to live
together in peace and harmony so you
have your way we have our way that we
live in kindness and we share this
message with compassion in love so what
else wrapping it up what also your final
thoughts in the matter
the final thought is the fact that we
have to be proud of who we are and in a
second and we need we need we don't need
to compromise our identity to make
others happy in the same token we're
obligated as Muslims to treat our
non-muslim friends with the best of
honor and in the mists of respect and
that's what we obligated I never
promised Allah Allah have orders to do
so likewise it's important for our
Christian brothers and sisters to know
that and to receive the message that
what was the main message of Jesus peace
be upon him who is the creator what is
the purpose of life and once they look
into the life of Jesus peace be upon him
in the Quran and of all the prophets in
the Quran in the Signum many of the
questions that they may have that you
know Trinity how can three and one be
the same how can God be their God being
a God dying they may have many questions
about their own faith about Jesus peace
be upon him and once they read the Quran
inshallah all of their questions will be
answered now they will realize who is
the creator and who is
this peace be upon him is a mighty
messenger with the message of inviting
humanity in the absolute oneness of God
I want to thank you all for making fuss
dr. burr waffle ask a Muslim a little
came up with a lot of you need to ask a
Muslim a solution calm become and we
have game peace now can we have dr.
Seville and thank you for being with us
we go ahead check him out at bay
peace.com you can check us out here at
the D show every week we have a new and
exciting show and again this is out of
the log sharing this message helping you
understand so you can develop a better
understanding why we serve you some
things
what is the wisdom hikmah behind us
doing some things in
things and we hope you enjoy this
episode subscribe if you haven't already
we'll see you next time
and all the messages across or of
Bahamut peace be with you
I said I'm awake